What I'm going to do with God logic is
I'm going to keep him in the context and
he's going to die. What he said, if we
go to context, I'm going to die. But
guess who's dying?
>> Not at all.
>> It's God. It's
God.
It's God.
>> All right.
So the topic of this debate is going to
be are the Gentiles saved?
>> Can Gentiles be saved?
>> Yes. Can Gentiles be saved? Cuz
obviously Gentiles got to accept Christ.
>> So can the Gentiles be saved?
>> We're going to do an hour. At the 50
minute mark, we are going to do five
minute closing statements. We have God
logic here and we have
>> Brother Yahawasa.
>> Brother Yahawasa. All right. So, as soon
as they start to talk, I will press uh
the little timer here. But before we do
that, um I want to have both of these
brothers to do a little two-minute
introduction. That will not be included
in the time. So, 2 minutes for you, 2
minutes for you, and then we'll
introduce the moderator for this debate.
All right, fellas. Go ahead. 2 minutes,
2 minutes. Uh you guys go ahead.
>> Y All right. What's going on, everybody?
Praise God.
>> Praise God. Praise God.
>> Hey, man. Beautiful debate with IP and
cap. Jesus is God. That was so clear.
And now we're going to see very clearly
that uh the Gentiles can obtain
salvation. I'm your host Avery aka God
Logic Apologetics.
[Applause]
>> And I just want to give a shout out to
ISUPK
for uh collaborating with us and
creating this platform like this. So
hopefully we can keep going. Um, you can
find me on YouTube, uh, Godlogic
Apologetics, Instagram, GodLoglogic GL,
uh, Tik Tok, Godlogic_2.
And so, uh, this is where you find this
content. All right, you want to see
more, just go ahead and follow us. All
right, let's get it.
>> Let's go. Let's get it.
>> All right, I'm Captain Yahawasa from the
School of Ramadarium. Shout out to ISUPK
for giving me this opportunity. Uh what
the brother I'mma listen what the
brother god logic is going to do. All
he's going to do is go to to the word
gentile stranger and he's going to use
the ambiguity of that word when that
word is polissimous. You understand? So
what I'm going to do with God logic is
I'm going to keep him in the context and
he's going to die
>> every time.
>> And when I and when I begin when I begin
to bring God logic to esquetology
>> you're going to die.
We don't die.
>> Let's go.
>> All right. So, this is Vocab Malone, the
reader. And here we have Bear. Here's
going to be the moderator for today.
[Music]
>> Got to listen.
>> Hey, did you guys agree? Who goes first?
>> Doesn't matter. It doesn't matter,
brother. You can go first.
>> Y'all start. Start.
>> Y'all start.
>> Time will start as soon as you start
talking.
>> All right. So, I'm going to die. Huh?
I'm going to die.
>> Well, look, this is what we got here,
man.
>> So, my my my brother here, he uh you
know, they don't believe the Gentiles
can be saved, meaning the
non-Israelites. He's going to try to
argue that uh Gentiles that are saved in
the scriptures are the Israelites and
the Israelites only. And so, salvation
cannot go to non-Jews, non-Israelites,
ethnically, uh Israelites can only be
saved. And so I think that it's good for
us to start off with the basics which
comes with the promise that was given to
Abraham. And when we look at this, and I
think that you're going to enjoy this,
too, in the Torah, cuz you like the
Torah.
>> I love it.
>> You love the Torah. All right. We love
the Torah. What's the only thing we do
around here, y'all?
>> We just read. So, we're just going to
read here. We got uh Genesis 12:3. And
in Genesis 12:3, this is what it says
here. It says, hold on, let me get it.
Let me get it. It says, "I will bless
those who bless you, and him who
dishonors you, I will curse, and in you
all the families of the earth shall be
blessed." Did it say some?
>> Did it say a little bit?
>> It said all, right?
>> So that's the Israelite families, right?
>> That's the non-Israelite families,
right?
>> So all families of the earth will be
blessed. That's the promise that God
first gave to Abraham. Then we see we go
over to Genesis chapter 17. He says that
you will be a father of many nations.
Not just one, right?
>> Not just one nation, but many nations.
Now, this isn't me. This isn't meaning
that oh, the Israelites. And now he's
smiling because he's like, wait, the
Israelites were scattered to many
nations. So, let's talk about the
Israelites. See, I read your mind. You
didn't know? Huh? You didn't know I
wasn't thinking that. Okay.
>> I wasn't thinking that, brother.
>> I hope not. I hope not. cuz then it
would be too easy. So, so I'm glad
you're not thinking that because he says
you'll be a father of many nations, not
that. So, the the nation of Israel,
that's one nation. That's one nation.
So, that means the other nations are
also included in the family of Abraham
as long as they believe in the Messiah.
All right. Now, I also want to talk
about this because we want to establish
the covenant.
>> I can't respond.
>> Yeah. Yeah. I'm just my opening. I'm
about to uh land the opening.
>> Go ahead. Okay. So with the opening
here, we got Deuteronomy chapter 29 that
talks about the covenant that's given to
the people of Israel. Now I like this
because he said if we go to the context,
we're going to die. So just real quick.
>> Yeah, we're going to die. Let's see if
we die here. Let's see which point dies.
So we got Deuteronomy 29 9-15. Watch
what it says here. It says, "Therefore
keep the words of this covenant and do
them that you may prosper in all that
you do." You are standing there. You are
standing today, all of you, before the
Lord your God, the heads of your tribes,
your elders, and your officers, and all
the men of Israel. That's all Israel,
right?
>> So, all the men of Israel are covered.
Then it goes, "Your little ones, your
wives." Now, guess what it says? And the
sojourer
>> who is in your camp,
>> so this is a non-Israelite,
>> right? from the one who chops your wood
to the one who draws your water so that
you may enter into the sworn covenant of
the Lord your God which the Lord your
God is making with you today. So just to
land this we see that the gentile the
non-Israelites are also accepted and
sworn into the covenant that's given to
Israel. So I'll land that point there. I
hear my opponent.
>> All right. You got Genesis 12 up.
>> Okay. You don't got Genesis 12 in the
Hebrew. Let's go through it.
>> Okay,
>> let's go through it.
>> My brother,
>> you ready?
>> In Genesis 12 in the Hebrew, when it
says vakov,
what does that mean?
>> You tell me.
>> That means in you all the families. The
U is referring to who?
>> Abraham.
>> Okay. So, that's Abraham.
>> Y.
>> So, the word families is in a feminine
plural that ends in the off. What does
that indicate? It indicates that it's
not just one family that Abraham is
going to be blessing, but all of the
families of the earth that that's going
to be blessing.
>> I got you. So, let me teach you the
importance of what this means. All
right, teach me. Okay. So, in the
Hebrew, the feminine is also often used
to complement or relate to an entity.
Who is the entity that is being related
to?
>> Abraham. So, what's being implied here
is that the indirect object, the U or
the the which is Abram, is the one from
where the families derive. That's what
the Hebrew shows. This is why even when
you go to Galatians 3, right? So when
you go to Galatians 3 and you begin to
show even the context on where he's
drawing that from, it's speaking about
Israelites. Let's go there.
>> This is horrible, brother.
>> Horrible, brother.
>> Yep.
>> Horrible. Horrible.
So in Galatians chapter 3, right, when
it says, "And the scripture foreseeing
that God will justify the heathen
through faith," right? So you're going
to say the heathen are non-Israelites,
correct?
>> Yep.
>> Okay. So when it says justify through
faith, what is he justifying them from?
>> So he's justifying them from their sins.
>> From their what?
>> From their sins.
>> From their sins. I got you. Uh,
>> so this is No, no, no. What's funny?
What's funny is
>> then sin is transgression of the law,
>> right?
>> So, let's go to Let's go to Acts. I know
you're going to go to Romans. Let's go
to Acts. Hold on. Wait, hold on. I
didn't cut you off. You got all that
time.
>> But I I didn't I didn't You got all that
time, brother.
>> This supposed to be an opening.
>> Hold on, brother. Oh, is this supposed
to be an opening?
>> Yeah.
>> I'm I'm ready to fight, brother. So,
let's just fight. Forget all that
opening up. Okay.
>> All right. So, in the book of Acts,
chapter 13,
>> right? You would have made you made a
lot of points. Can I respond to
something?
>> One second. In the book of Acts, chapter
13 and verse 38, let's look what it
says. But it known unto you men and
brethren, that through this man is
preached unto you the forgiveness of
sins. And by him all that believe are
justified from all things from from all
things from which
>> Who are justified? Is that who did it
say is justified?
>> Who is justified? Let's go to verse 26.
No, no, no. Read what you just read. I'm
going to go to verse 26. Hold on. This
is who's justified. This is who's
justified. This is who's justified.
Check it out. It says, "Men and
brethren, men and brethren, children of
the stock of Abraham and whosoever among
you." So, who's justified? The children
of Israel. Got you. So, let's go back.
Wait, wait, wait. Can I Can we talk
about that? Absolutely. All right. Cool.
So we This is Acts 13, right?
>> Yeah. So we're going to read Acts 13.
We're going to read this context here.
Now Now you don't you don't you don't
know where you cooked yourself. I mean I
think you do, but then you try to skip
over that.
>> Not at all. Not at all. Because because
you read and I asked you to repeat it
and you were scared to repeat it for
some reason.
>> Not at all.
>> So you read it said all who believe,
correct?
>> All who believe, correct?
>> Will be justified. Now you all Yeah.
Let's see who the all is. So go ahead go
ahead and read it for After the meeting
of the synagogue broke up, many Jews and
devout converts to Judaism.
>> Wait, devout what?
>> Devout converts to Judaism.
>> So this means this means that they
weren't in Judaism before.
>> Devout converts to Judaism.
>> So these non-Israelites are able to
convert to Judaism, come into the belief
of the true God. What verse are you
reading? Justified by their faith.
What verse are you reading?
What verse are you reading? What verse
are you reading?
>> This is what verse is this?
>> Acts 13:43.
>> That's not the verse I read. Yeah, this
is the context, right?
>> You told me that if we go to Look, you
smell it, too. He told Hey, what he
said? If we go to context, I'm going to
die. But guess who's dying?
>> Not at all.
>> Not at all. Not at all. So, hold
context, man.
>> So, in Acts chapter 13 and 38, it says,
we just read.
>> All right. So check it out. When it
says, "And by all that believe are
justified from all things, from which he
cannot be justified by the law of
Moses." Who was under the law of Moses?
Brother, I wait, hold on a second. I'm
glad you asked that cuz I just read it
to you. In Deuteronomy 29, who was there
that was under the law in the covenant?
Who got sworn in into the covenant?
>> The children of Israel. And who else was
there? The stranger. Thank you. Who was
the stranger? Just who is the stranger
in the context? Look, good question. The
stranger in the context, it says first
it it names all the men of Israel. Then
it means their names their wives and
their children, their little ones. Then
it says, "And the souljourers."
>> So is in your camp. So who's in your
camp? The ones who's chopping your wood
and keeping your fire.
>> So this is this is Hold on real quick.
This is simple to understand.
>> Relax. This is simple to understand.
This is talking about a class system.
You understand? a class system of the
Israelites.
>> Really?
>> That's who this is talking about.
Absolutely.
>> So, wait, just to be clear, sir, where
my my question, where did the
souljourner come from? Who you're saying
that this is an Israelite? Where did the
souljourner come from? Uh, who was that
that did not travel with Moses when they
got out of the Exodus?
>> Where did the Israelites come from?
>> Which which showjourner in the context?
>> The souljourer is in the camp of Moses.
Okay. They're with Moses.
>> Talking about in Deuteronomy 29. Yes.
>> That is an Israelite. So, a journey
where they come from. So a jourer does
not he came from Egypt with Moses.
>> Okay. So a jourer So a jourer does not
simply mean somebody that comes from
another land. It's a class system.
>> No, it's a Hold on. Hold up.
>> Yes, it is.
>> Okay. Hold up. Hey, hold it down. Hold
it down. Hold it down.
>> So So So y'all, what's up? Listen.
>> Uhhuh.
>> Who who all who all left the Exodus in
uh with with Moses?
>> The children of Israel.
>> Very good. Now with the children of
Israel, they left. Were there any Were
there any Israelites outside of Egypt
before they left Egypt?
>> Were there any Israelites out of Egypt
>> Yes.
>> I couldn't answer that.
>> Okay. The answer is no. They were all
there, right? Because you have uh Jacob
that settled there and then they began
to populate Egypt, right? They populated
their land. So, they all was forming
within Egypt. There were no Israelites
outside of that. The souljourer is a
stranger, a foreign person who's not
within your land, who's not part of you.
And so what this is saying, hold on.
What this is saying, there's all the men
of Israel that was with Moses. This is
Deuteronomy. This is after Exodus. This
is after the Exodus of Egypt. So all the
Israelites are with Moses. A matter of
fact, it even says all the men of Israel
and their wives and their children. Then
it says, "And the souljourer who's in
your camp."
>> It's a wrap, bro. So you got the
souljourers who are non-Israelites that
are being sworn in into the covenant.
No problem. All you got to do All you
got to do is keep reading. It's simple.
So it says in verse 12, it says that
thou shouldest enter into the covenant
with the Lord thy God, and into his oath
which the Lord thy God maketh with thee
this day, that he may establish thee
today for a people unto himself, and
that he may be unto th thee a God. and
he hath said unto thee, and hath also
sworn unto the fathers, Abraham, Isaac,
and Jacob.
>> Awesome.
>> Right. So, the the covenant in the
context is dealing with Abraham, Isaac,
and Jacob. You're right. Hold on. I'm
not done.
>> I'm not done cuz I like sources.
>> So do I.
>> I got the Hebrew right here.
>> I like sources. All right.
>> You good, brother?
>> I don't know. I don't know this,
brother.
>> Get him out of here. I don't know this,
but he he smell he's inebriated. He's
inebriated. He's
>> inebriated.
>> We're good. We're good.
>> Good. We're good.
>> All right. So, this right here, can you
uh reload the point that you're making?
Uh what I'm what I'm what I'm making is
is that the stranger in that context is
an Israelite. It's not just simply
talking about somebody from somewhere
else. It's talking about a class system
of somebody who is employed. And I'm
going to show you this in this source
and I I get your number. I'll send you
the source. So it said more striking.
This is talking about Deuteronomy 29. It
says more striking is the language
attributed to Moses in charging the
judges. Hear causes between your
brethren and judge righteously. I'm
going to get I'mma drop down to the
point. One second. It says here causes
between your brethren and judges
righteously between man and his brother.
Between man and his girl.
>> What chapter is this?
>> This is this is I'm I'm reading a book a
source. I'm going I'm going to give you
the source. Don't worry. I want
>> I'm going to give you Bible in a second.
>> Okay, we're good. Then it says it says
it is difficult to imagine causing
contention with mere strangers whereas
differences between employer and
employee. So within this book in
somebody who actually parses out the
Hebrew is telling you that that sword
journer is an employee. That's what that
is. So that what is this is showing you
in the context? This is a class system
in Israel. Very simple to understand.
I'll let you have the last word for
that.
>> I appreciate it. So I Hey, ladies and
gentlemen, he said he's going to bring
me a source. He brought a book. By who?
>> I got you right now. You got me right
now. I got you right now. It is called
It's called the status. It's called the
status of labor in ancient Israel.
>> By who? I got you. Okay. So now all I
got to do is zoom out, brother. It's
okay. So now I got to do is zoom out,
brother.
>> Watch the difference here. The
difference from what he brought and what
I brought. Now what I have is I have the
lexicon which is the biblical breakdown
of the Hebrew and the Greek words and
the Aramaic. It tells you the
definitions, the meanings, the usages.
I'm not giving you guys some unknown
author and some anonymous author.
But watch this. So this is what it says
in the lexicon. The word G, right? U it
says a sojourer. Alien. Aliens in the
plural.
>> Foreigners. Immigrants. Sojourers.
Souljourers, strangers, strangers,
strangers. So, my question to you is
this. Yes, sir.
>> Can you pull me up a lexicon that
demonstrates that the word GR is used to
to demonstrate a class system?
>> I just I just showed you
>> No, I need a lexicon.
>> No, it's not within the lexicon. It's
within the parsing of the Hebrew.
>> It's within the parsing of the Hebrew.
That's good.
>> So, let me ask you a question. Hold on.
Let me ask you a question. I need to ask
you a question.
>> I'll let you ask a Is there anywhere in
the Bible that G,
>> the author of that book
>> is is related to a Hebrew? Yes or no?
>> Yes or no?
>> What's your question? Sorry.
>> Is there anywhere in the Hebrew in the
in the Bible where in the Hebrew G is is
used for an Israelite? Yes or no?
>> You have to demonstrate that to me.
>> That's your
>> Are you serious?
>> Yeah, I'm serious.
>> No problem. So, this is the book of 2
Chronicles. In
>> the book of 2 Chronicles,
>> 2 Chronicles,
>> chapter 15,
>> when it says, "As you were sojourners
for Egypt?"
>> No.
>> Okay.
>> Uh, one second.
>> Uh, this is the book of 2 Chronicles 15
and verse 9. All right, slow down.
>> And it says, "And he gathered,
>> let me catch up to you. Let me catch up
to you.
>> And he gathered all Judah and Benjamin
and the strangers
with them out of Ephraim and Manessa."
Was Was Ephraim and Manessa called
strangers? Yes or no? No, no. You just
missed it. Guys, this this is this Hey,
this is where reading comprehension got
to come.
>> Wow.
>> Do me this favor.
>> Y What's up, I love how you read. Can
you read that one more time? I'm going
to show you. No problem.
>> And he gathered all Judah and Benjamin
>> and the strangers with them out of
Ephraim and Manessa.
>> Thank you. So, the strangers out of
Ephraim and Manessa. Not that Ephraim
and Manessa are strangers among
Israelites, but that
look, I'm telling you, it's reading
comprehension.
>> Horrible. It's horrible.
>> It's reading comprehension. Horrible.
>> I'm telling you. Look, he said that's
horrible.
>> Horrible. So,
when we go to the context, you're dead.
You're dead. But look, guys, notice how
clear this is. It's so clear that among
Ephraim and Manessa, they had
non-Israelites with them. You're proving
my point. Now hold on saying in the
context. Let me also stack this. Hold
on. Let me stack this. This. Okay. Can
you read it? Horrible. Let me stack
this. Horrible. He he said now in
Deuteronomy 29, he said that the
covenant is dealing with Abraham, Isaac,
and Jacob, the forefathers. You're
exactly right. So what did the promise
say with the covenant of Abraham? That
in you all the families will be blessed.
Listen. Look, you you acknowledging that
the covenant is talk is relating to what
God said to Abraham is proving my
initial point. I established it that
God's covenant with Abraham included
everyone.
>> I literally showed you within the Hebrew
that that is specifically dealing that
is specifically dealing with
>> uh the people that came from Abraham.
Very simple.
>> No, you didn't. You didn't. Yes, I did.
You didn't bring me a single lexicon.
You didn't bring me nothing.
>> I I showed you in the Hebrew
>> in in Genesis 12.
Genesis 12 and 3. I said, "Are you
looking at the Hebrew?" In Genesis 12
and 3, it right there when it says in
you all the families of the earth shall
be blessed within the Hebrew, it is
indicating that those families derive
from Abraham.
>> I got a question. Very simple to
understand. So when when they left the
Exodus, was it only Israelites that left
or what?
>> No. So there were non-Israelites with
them.
>> Yes.
>> So non-Israelites were in the camp of
Moses,
>> right? Yes.
>> Okay. In Deuteronomy 29, who is it
addressing? Is it addressing just the
Israelites that's there, or does he say
he's addressing everyone that's there?
>> In Deuteronomy 29, starting at verse 9,
>> no problem.
>> Starting at verse 10, 10 to 15.
>> Yep. In Deuteronomy 29, not even all the
tribes are there.
>> Can you all the tribes are not here in
Deuteronomy 29? That's right. In verse
one, it says, "These are the words of
the covenant which the Lord commanded
Moses to make with the children of
Israel in the land of Moab beside the
covenant which he made in Horat." Right?
So when you drop down
>> Uh-huh. very simple, man.
>> Read verse 15. Read verse 15.
>> Yeah. Now guys, listen to his point. His
point was
>> This is why But this is why it says
this.
>> Hold on. Watch this. I know. Watch this.
His point is is that not all the tribes
of Israel are present. Read verse 15.
>> Correct. It says, "But with with him
that standeth here, with us this day
before the Lord our God, and also with
him that is not here, with us this day."
Exactly. So that's what is this showing.
The people that are standing here are
getting this covenant
>> and the Israelites that are not here are
getting this covenant. Very simple. But
but notice this. That all
>> You're proving my point.
>> No. Yes. Y'all will stop it, bro.
>> Proving my point, brother. Yo, what's
up? Listen. What what what we
demonstrated is that you trying to say
that not all the uh tribes of Israel is
there is present
>> is a is a non it doesn't do anything to
me because it addresses even those that
are not present there in that day right
as we just read. However, here's the
point. The point is is that it addresses
all the men of Israel, their wives and
their children. And then it says, "And
the swordjourer, the stranger who is
with you in your camp, these are
non-Israelites who are sworn into the
covenant." My brother, you've got to
deal. So you got to Okay, so then you
have to look. This is what you have to
do for me.
>> I need you to demonstrate for me an
Israelite. Wait, listen. An Israelite
being called a stranger.
>> No, I just did.
>> Got listen to what I'm asking.
>> Go ahead, brother.
>> Demonstrate for me a souljourner. And
no, you didn't, by the way.
>> Yes, I did, by the way.
>> Okay. a a souljourer who is an Israelite
>> right after the exodus. Where are these?
>> This is what you're not understanding
that my position is and you can disagree
if you want. My position is that this is
a class system. That's why that
swordjourer is somebody who is employed.
And I just read a source of somebody who
parses out the Hebrew and it showed that
that's what this is talking about.
>> What Hebrew did they what lexicon did
they quote?
>> I I'm going to have to go into it.
Simple. No worries.
>> Simple. Okay. Good. What Hebrew
dictionary did they quote?
>> I'm going to have to go into it. I can I
can we can we can
>> my brother. What What lexical summary
did they quote?
>> What? Listen,
>> you want me to trust you, but what? I
know you don't got to trust me.
>> We don't trust you. What other like
where Cap at? Cap, where you at, man?
What you say? We don't trust you, man.
>> Oh, you behind. Yeah. Look at him. He
think just eating his popcorn like damn,
I'm going to get cooked.
>> Not at all. Not at all. So, you ready to
move on from this or you going to keep
playing right here? Yeah. Cool. No, no,
I'm not ready to move on.
>> No, we're going to have to move on. You
Every verse Every verse that you brought
up every verse that you brought up, I
dealt with.
>> I would like for you to deal with
certain things in esquetology. So, I I I
have some questions for you, brother.
>> But you can't escape it.
>> I have some questions. No problem. We
could get back there in a second.
>> No, it's not. Get back.
>> No, we're going to have to move on,
brother. We We If not, we're going to
keep talking about what does this mean?
What does that mean? Very simple. I I'll
have no problem moving on if you concede
to the point.
>> No, I don't concede to the point. Those
are Israelites. We ain't going nowhere.
Those are Israelites.
>> Those are Israelites, brother.
>> Not at all. We don't have that.
>> We You guys have to decide what we're
going to do as far as the back and
forth, right? So,
>> we're doing good.
>> Oh, no. I thought we good. Yeah.
>> Okay, cool. We're good. You guys are
good. I just want to make sure you guys
are good.
>> I ain't got no problem with him. I just
I just want to be able
>> I want to be able I want to be able to
present a scripture. Every scripture
that has been brought up has been
presented by him and I simply dealt with
it. That's it.
>> You didn't though. I simply dealt with
it. Just cuz you Listen, just cuz you
disagree
>> doesn't mean it does not mean that I did
not deal with it. I answered the
question. Just cuz you don't like the
answer to the question doesn't mean I
didn't answer the question. So now that
Hold on, hold on. I'm I'm going to let
you talk. I promise. I promise I'm going
to let you talk right here. So just
because you did not agree with my answer
once again that the sojourer within
Deuteronomy 29 is talking about a class
system.
>> Yeah.
>> And that in Genesis 12 those families
are talking about the families that
derive from Abraham. Just because you
disagree doesn't mean I I didn't answer
it.
>> Okay. So this is my problem. Simple. My
problem is simple. My problem is not
that I disagree with you. My problem is
that you didn't substantiate what you
said.
>> Absolutely.
>> So notice notice the difference. The
difference between us is I brought you a
lexical source saying exactly what I
said. I brought you scripture word for
word said exactly what I said. When I
asked you basic questions based on the
context I'm supposed to die in, you
died.
>> Not at all. Not at all. That's my point,
bro. You You got to substantiate it.
>> I already did, brother.
>> Okay. So, I'll ask again. On what basis
of the Hebrew language do you have? Not
just somebody said so. That's an appeal
to authority fallacy. appeal to
authority. It's somebody simply that is
parsing out the Hebrew and he lists a
group of sources that he parsed it out
within the book
>> where show us the source he's paring it
out in.
>> Brother, this is not a PowerPoint uh uh
debate on YouTube. It's face to face.
So, what I'm telling you is what I'm
telling you is I showed you the source
and what we have to do is you're just
going to have to understand. We're going
to agree to disagree, bro. Let me read
this and let's move on.
>> Let me read this.
Let's get Leviticus.
>> Let us talk.
>> Let's get the Leviticus source
>> because we we going to show you. I'm
going ask who the souljour is here.
>> 1713.
>> So any man from the sons of Israel.
>> Or from the souljourers who sojourn
among them.
>> Stop there. Stop there. Read it one more
time.
>> Everybody. Everybody. I need y'all to
listen and key in closely. Go ahead.
Wait. Wait. Y'all stop. I need you to
hear this.
>> I'm listening. So any from the sons of
Israel.
>> Wait, stop. Who's that? Who's that
talking about?
>> The sons of Israel.
>> Who are they?
>> Who are the sons of Israel? The sons of
Israel.
>> Is that does that in encapsulate the
whole tribe? All the tribes.
>> Depends on the context. Where you at?
We're in Leviticus. Yes. Okay. Gotcha.
So he said, "Guys, it's okay." He said,
"Yes." In Leviticus, in the context, the
sons of Israel is includ Leviticus
chapter uh 17.
>> Leviticus 17:13. any man from the sons
of Israel.
>> What translation are you reading?
>> Or from the sojourers sojourns among
them.
>> Yeah. So if you want to go get it in
your
>> What translation are you reading? I'm
asking. Okay.
>> Yeah, that's fine. So notice now watch
how your concession it helped me. Look,
you just acknowledged that in Leviticus,
>> the sons of Israel talked to is includes
all the tribes of Israel. Everyone
that's an Israelite is included in the
sons of Israel. But then it makes a
distinction. It says not just the sons
of Israel but who
>> from the sojourers who sojourn among
them.
>> So who are the sojourers who are
sojouring among all of Israel?
>> Uh people who are not Israelites.
>> Beautiful context.
>> Beautiful say about them.
>> That has nothing to do with Deuteronomy
29.
>> It has everything to do with it because
notice all of this is happening in
Moses's hand.
>> So hold on. So once again, once again,
>> in Leviticus, in the same book,
>> yeah,
>> does it call Israelites strangers?
>> You got to show me the verse.
>> No problem. Leviticus 25.
>> You got it.
>> Leviticus 25. Read that for me.
>> Go ahead.
>> This is the book of Leviticus.
>> Leviticus 25.
>> This is the book of Leviticus, chapter
25,
>> and verse 23.
>> Go ahead.
>> The land shall not be sold forever. No,
I want where it says the
>> for the land is mine for ye are
strangers and sojourers with me.
>> You are what?
>> Ye are strangers and sojourers with me.
Let me read and let me read. I got you.
Hold on. I got you. Read that speaking
straight to the point.
>> This is the book of Leviticus chapter 25
and verse 35.
>> Leviticus 25 and 35. Just one second,
brother.
>> I just read 23 and 23.
>> I've been impatient with you, brother. I
am reading 23. Hold on. Hold on. I like
to go.
>> Hold on. Let me talk. I've been patient
with you.
>> You understand?
>> Yeah. I like to go point for point.
>> There you go. We're going to go point
for point. Read that. Now you're giving
me what I want.
>> This is the book of Deuteronomy. Locky.
This is the book of Leviticus, chapter
25 and verse 35.
>> Uhhuh.
>> And if thy brother be waxing poor,
>> who's the brother here?
>> The Israelites. Read.
>> And fallen in decay with thee.
>> Uh-huh.
>> Then thou shalt relieve him.
>> Uh-huh. Yay. Though he be a stranger.
>> Though he be a what?
>> Though he be a stranger.
>> This prove this prove the class system.
That's right.
>> Because this stranger right here is an
Israelite that is being employed by
another Israelite.
>> That's right.
>> This proves the class system. Right.
Read it again from the top.
>> And if thy brother be wax and poor,
>> come on.
>> And fallen decay with thee,
>> Then thou shalt believe him.
>> Go ahead.
>> Yay. Though he be a stranger,
>> though he be a what?
>> Though he be a stranger.
>> Is this stranger an Israelite? Yes or
no?
>> Yeah.
>> Or a suitor.
>> Type it up. Type it up for God logic,
man. He got honest.
>> Watch this. Can I Can I respond to this?
Go ahead. Go ahead. Go ahead. Go ahead.
Go ahead.
>> So you go ahead. Go ahead. Go ahead.
>> What did you say was going to kill me?
>> I was so
>> context.
>> Context.
>> Cuz you just said that stranger is an
Israelite.
>> Now watch this. Watch this.
>> And if you drop down, wait, hold on.
Hold on.
>> There's a different stranger there.
>> We're going to see. According to this
context, who are the strangers among?
>> Who are the what?
>> Who are the strangers among?
>> Yes.
>> Israelites.
>> Okay. And when is this talking about?
>> When is this talking about?
>> Yes.
>> This is when they're in the wilderness.
>> Yeah. But but hold on. Notice how it's
talking about
>> he's giving he's giving the law to the
children of Israel in the wilderness.
>> In the wilderness. Did they possess the
land?
>> No.
>> Okay. So,
>> that's that's why it's a what they did
was they gave the law to the children of
Israel in the wilderness for what? Watch
how we break this.
>> He gave the law to the children of
Israel in the wilderness so they so they
know what to do when they're in the
land. Beautiful. So that right there,
hold on. So that right there in
Leviticus 25 and 35, you just admitted
that that stranger is an Israelite.
>> I sure did.
>> So there you go. Now watch. So this is a
Are you going to let me lead now? Go
ahead.
>> All right. So follow me now just like I
follow you. So I agree with you that in
this context, the souljourer is the
Israelite. Now, when I ask you for a for
a reason, when is this talking about? Is
this talking about when they're in the
wilderness with Moses or is it talking
about after they possess the land?
>> Both.
>> Where's Where does it say that? Where
does it say that while they're in the
wood?
>> Because it show I just showed you in
Deuteronomy which is afterwards as
they're sitting there.
>> Absolutely.
>> No. No. No.
>> You just read the verse and it says when
you possess, right?
>> Let's read it again.
>> Okay. Yeah. Let's go ahead.
>> Let's read it again. Before you read, we
got an announcement.
>> 30 minutes coming up. 30 minutes.
Let's read Leviticus 25 and35 again.
>> This the book of Leviticus.
>> Wasn't there a verse before that?
>> I'll read them both.
>> No, no. Leviticus 25 and 35. That's the
point I wanted. Yeah, but there was a
verse you read before that.
>> Hold on, brother.
>> Hold on, brother. Go ahead. Read it.
>> This is the book of Leviticus 25 and
verse 35.
>> And if thy brother be wax and poor and
fallen in decay with thee,
>> Uh-huh.
>> then
>> So, who once again, who is this brother
here?
>> Israel. Okay, there you go. Read.
>> Then shalt thou relieve him. Yay. Though
he be a stranger or a sojourer that he
may live with thee.
>> Yeah.
>> So that that stranger is an Israelite,
right?
>> Cool. No problem. You said you said Hold
on. I just want to say this real quick.
You said
>> for the audience right now. You've been
saying a lot, man.
>> You said that there's nowhere in the
Bible.
>> You said there's nowhere in the Bible
that what?
>> I never said that. You didn't say that.
I never said that there's no I never I
never said that. Go ahead, brother. Go
ahead, brother. Go ahead.
>> Yeah. This is what I said. I
demonstrated that contextually the
souljourers that's with Israel spec
specifically in the time they're with
Israel, these are non-Israelites. I
never said that Israelites are not
called strangers or souljourers. I never
said that. I just asked you to show me
and I and and I asked you to show me
because I knew that the context you
would take me to would kill you.
Remember? So, I'm going just use your
language. Now, watch what it says here.
Now, this is the ESV. The KJV messes you
up. It says, "Now, now if a brother of
yours," and this is this is in the
Hebrew as well. Now, if a brother of
yours becomes poor and his means with uh
and his means with with regard to your f
you
are to sustain him. It's okay. It's all
right. It's going to be embarrassing.
>> Like a sjourer.
>> You're reading uh 35, correct? Yeah. For
35. like a souljourer. Not that he is a
souljourer, but you treat him like a
souljourer. Like a souljourer or a
foreign resident that he may live with
you. Now watch this guys. So this
already destroyed that. But I wanted to
even grant you I wanted to grant you
this because even your point even I
grant you it doesn't hurt me because in
the context in Leviticus 25 it's talking
about when you possess the land
>> not when you're in the wilderness with
Moses right now but when you possess the
land now here my question when they when
they possess the land was the land
divided among the tribes
>> absolutely
>> okay so another tribe
>> that's why that's why in in in
Chronicles I just showed you that those
strangers those strangers that came from
Ephraim and Manessa. Those guys those
strangers strangers guys the strangers
let them do it.
>> That's why I just showed you those
strangers that came from Ephraim and
Manessa were Israelites.
>> No, they wasn't.
>> That's You just proved it. No,
>> because they divided the land amongst
each other.
>> So they divided the land amongst I got
you. They divided the land amongst each
other. And so then now the Israelites,
the sojourers can be sojourers of
Israelites within the land. Right. Is
that correct? Say that again. That's
that Israelites can be souljourers in
another part of the land that was given
to them because they're in another Yes.
Right. Okay. Now, here's my question. Or
>> just like But just like this shows.
>> Please stop there.
>> But I'm just going to say but just like
that show.
Hold on.
>> All right. Go ahead. All right. So,
here's my question. Go ahead. In
Deuteronomy 29, was they in the land?
>> No. Okay. So, there was no land that was
divided among the Israelites. They were
in the wilderness. Is that correct? Yes.
So there were no Israelite souljourers
among Israelites yet in Deuteronomy 29
when the souljourers were sworn into the
covenant. So this is why I said the the
context is going to kill you because
according to the context this there's no
divided land where there's souljourers
of their brothers. Here the souljourers
are non-Israelites that are in the
wilderness. No land is given you
>> because the swordjourer is indicating
somebody of a class system.
>> I proved that in Leviticus 25 and35.
>> I literally proved it. I literally
proved it, brother. I I need to see it.
I just read it. Just cuz you read it
again, brother. No, no, no. Read it
again. The book of Leviticus. Wait, the
verse. That's the verse that I want to
ask.
>> That's the verse that proves
>> You're not hearing my question. My
question is, where is this class system
of souljourer being implemented?
>> Right here.
>> No, I know the verse, but where are
they?
>> They're in the wilderness.
>> No, they're not in Leviticus.
>> In Leviticus, it says, "When you possess
the possess the land, do this." Right.
Yes.
>> Okay. So, it's totally
>> Hold on. They're not going to apply this
law also while they're in the
wilderness.
>> They're not No, no, not hold on. They're
not going to apply the laws that are
given to them even though they're in the
wilderness.
>> No, notice notice the bait and switch.
>> No, I didn't make it switch.
>> Yeah, let me let me show you.
>> They're not going to apply this law even
though they're in the wilderness.
>> Let me answer you. Go ahead, brother.
>> So, notice how you tried to twist the
words. I didn't say that they're not
going to follow the laws until uh while
they're in the wilderness. What I said
was is that in context what he's talking
about how to treat certain people that
come amongst them when they possess the
land. So the whole caveat is the whole
umbrella is when you possess the land do
this. However, in Deuteronomy 29, this
is before they possess the land and they
have souljourers with them. So there's
not an Israelite souljourer yet.
Everybody's an Israelite and is
accounted for. Now the souljourer is a
nonIsraelite
according to the covenant. It's over.
>> I disagree, brother.
>> Why disagree? Okay. Why?
>> I I just read it. I just read it and I
just continue to repeat myself. All you
do keep All you keep doing is repeating
yourself, brother. That's all you keep
doing. But e even let's say even if even
if that was right, what does this have
to do with gentile salvation?
>> Excellent. Excellent question. So So
here's
>> not at all. He has an excellent
question.
>> Not at all. He said, "Even if I grant
you this position, what does this have
to do?" Excuse me. With non-Israelite
salvation. Correct. Right. So, according
to you, those who are of the covenant
are the ones who receive salvation. Yes.
>> Yes.
>> Okay. So, the fact that non-Israelite
souljourers are being sworn into the
covenant means that they have access to
salvation. No. Even based on your
standards?
>> No. Not at all. So if wait if if a
stranger if a non-Israelite is if is
part of the covenant is being sworn into
the covenant. Do they have access to
salvation?
>> Yes. But they weren't. That's the point.
That's the point. They weren't.
>> Okay. So hold on. Let me let me ask you
a question. Been very patient with you,
brother. Been very patient with you.
Okay. So can we can we move to the book
of Revelation?
>> Do you concede?
>> No, I don't concede. Let's move to the
book of Revelation, bro.
>> All right. Revelation 2. Notice I I
ain't went to the New Testament yet. I
just been in the That's where we got to
go. I just been in the We got to go.
That's where we got to go.
>> That's where we got to go, brother.
>> Read that.
>> Old Testament.
>> Come on.
>> I love it, brother.
>> I love it. Go ahead.
>> I I have one more question for you, too,
based on this. But I
>> I got you. I got you. Read. Read,
brother. It's the book of Revelation
chapter 2 and verse 26. And he that
overcomemeth and keepeth my works
unto the end to him will I give power
over the nations.
>> Who are these nations?
>> I'm sorry. What what chapter and verses
is this?
>> That's Revelation 2 and 26.
>> Okay. Can you one more time?
>> I got you.
>> I got to get it up. Hold on.
>> Read it.
>> Revelation uh the book of Revelation
chapter 2
>> and verse 26.
>> And he that overcomemeth
>> Uhhuh. and keepeth my works unto the
end. To him will I give power over the
nations.
>> Who is he giving power over the nations?
>> Those who are against God's people.
>> Those who are who are against God's
people are against God's people.
>> So who's getting this power?
>> The people of God.
>> Read the next verse.
>> And he shall rule them.
>> I can't believe you.
>> A rod of iron.
>> And as the vessels of a potter
>> shall he be broken to shivers. So, so
this is going to happen with the
children of God ruling over the other
nations. Correct.
>> Is that right?
>> Correct.
>> I'm sorry. Say that again.
>> Uh-huh.
>> So, he's going to give this to the
children of God to rule over the other
nations. Correct.
>> Yeah. To give to give them power.
>> To give them power and rule over the
other nations. Read it over the world.
>> No. Read it again.
>> Cuz this is what he's doing to the other
nations. Read.
>> And we about to see. And we about to see
who these people are.
>> The book of Revelation 2 and verse 26.
>> Uh-huh. And he that overcomemeth and
keepeth my works unto the end, to him
will I give power over the nations, and
he shall rule them with a rod of iron,
and as the vessels of a potter shall
they be broken.
>> That boy better. Okay. So, who So, who's
ruling over these nations again? Can I
answer you?
>> Yes.
>> Okay. I'm I'm going to let the Bible
speak. Okay. Go ahead.
>> All right. So, here he asked me, who are
these people, right? So, let's see. Who
are these people that Christ gave
victory over over these nations? Right.
over these people that go against them.
It says here in Revelation 5 verse 9 and
10, it says, "Worthy," and they sang a
new song, saying, "Worthy are you to
take the scroll and to open the its
seals because you were slain and
purchased for God with your blood people
from every tribe and tongue and people
and nations.
and you made them to be a kingdom and
priest to our God and they will reign
upon the earth forever. I cannot believe
you went to Revelation. So, who are
they? They're the people of God from
every people, nation, language, and
tongue. So, you're telling me the people
of God from all other nations are going
to rule over who?
>> The the nations that rise up against
>> in Revelation 2. Where is John the
Revelator quoting this from?
>> Pamos.
>> Where is he quoting this from?
>> Oh, you mean the scripture pastor? You
got to tell me.
>> You don't know where he's quoting this
from?
>> You got to tell me, man. Teach me.
>> Read.
>> It's the book of Psalms chapter 2.
>> And verse 8. Ask of me and I shall give
thee for the heathen for inheritance.
>> Ask of who?
>> Ask of me.
>> Okay. Who's the one that needs to do the
asking
>> in the context?
>> People.
>> What people? What What people did it
say?
>> What people? What people did it say?
>> Read it again.
>> It's the book of Psalms chapter 2 and
verse 8. Go ahead. Ask of me
>> and I shall give thee the heathen for
thine inheritance.
>> Who's the heathen here?
>> Those who are going against God.
>> No, those are those are non-Israelites.
>> No, no, wait. Keep reading. Wait, wait,
wait. Where does it say?
>> Keep reading. Listen to the book of
Psalm 2 and verse 8. Ask of me, and I
shall give thee a heathen for thine
inheritance, and the uttermost parts of
the earth for thy possession.
>> Go ahead.
>> Thou shalt break them with a rod of
iron.
>> Beautiful. and thou shalt dash them to
pieces like a potter's vessel.
>> So, this is where John the Revelator is
quoting this from.
>> Okay,
>> so John the Revelator is literally
saying he's giving power to the children
of Israel to rule over the nations and
Christ return.
>> All right, let me Here's my question to
you. Very simple. I got you. Within
Israel, is it is it is it only Israel
that's within Israel or do they always
have sojourers with them or non
Israelites?
>> There's not Israelites that
>> Thank you. So those who are sided with
Israel, who believe in the one God share
in that victory over the nations that
rise up against them. Not at all. Just
like when we just read here, it says
from a people from every tribe, every
tongue, every nation gets the kingdom
and he rises them as priests to God. So
according to the verses that you're
talking about, all of these are
believers who come into the faith from
everywhere who God has given victory.
>> What are you doing? We're going to I'm
I'm going to go there in a second cuz
I'm still proving my point in Revelation
2. It's very easy to understand.
>> Hebrews uh uh
>> Isaiah 60.
>> What about this? I need an answer to
this.
>> I'm going to answer that. I'm still
proving my point on who these people are
in Revelation.
>> I just refuted your point.
>> You didn't refute it.
>> Your esquetology is horrible.
>> If it's horrible, tell me who this is.
Who is it?
>> Hold on, bro. I'm going to go there in a
second. I'm going to drive.
>> I promise I'm going to go there in a
second. I promise.
>> Now, right now,
>> go there now.
>> Isaiah.
>> Go there now.
>> Read it.
>> The book of Isaiah
>> chapter 60 and verse 10.
>> Straight to the point.
>> And the sons of strangers shall build up
thy walls.
>> Wait, what's this?
>> This Isaiah 60 and 10.
>> So, we shuffle to Isaiah. I'm going to
go back to Revelation because you're
saying, this is what you're saying.
You're saying that the children of God
in Revelation 2 are all nations and not
strictly Israelites
>> according to Revelation.
>> I'm going to show you in prophecy that
you're wrong.
>> Oh, so read. So, you're wrong. The Bible
read
>> this. The book of Isaiah chapter 60 and
verse 10. And the sons of strangers.
>> Who are these strangers here?
>> You got to tell me.
>> No, you tell me. Who are the That's the
question. You got you got to read the
context.
>> It's the book of Isaiah 16:10.
>> And the sons of strangers shall build up
thy walls.
>> These are non-Israelites.
>> Okay. Read.
>> So whose walls are they building up?
>> Which which strangers are these?
>> Whose walls are they building up?
>> Israel. Which strangers are these?
>> So the So those strangers, those
non-Israelites
are building up.
>> Which ones?
>> These are people that are in the
kingdom.
>> No.
>> And yes, they are.
>> Wait, which one?
>> Yes, they are. That that's what they're
building.
>> Answer the question. Which strangers are
these that are going to be building and
serving Israel? Which strangers are
they?
>> Read it.
>> You're going to see. I'm going to read
the context. I got you.
>> I got you. Read. Just so you know, the
book of Isaiah.
>> I do know, brother.
>> Then tell me right now. Wait, wait,
wait. Before you read says, you know,
who are they?
>> These are the strangers that fought
against Israel.
>> Boom. Thank you. So now,
>> all the strangers are going to fight
against Israel.
>> No, no, they're not.
>> Yes, they are, brother.
>> Wait. So even the str even you notice
this doesn't make any sense. You just
said that among Israel are strangers
that side with Israel. Are they going to
fight against I didn't say that.
>> You literally said that.
>> No, I said that there were strangers
that so adjourned amongst Israel. It
does not mean that they just sat there
and and did everything with them and for
them and they they were pleased to dwell
with them. Not at all.
>> Are we done already?
>> Yeah. Read that. So book of Isaiah
16:10.
And the sons of strangers shall build up
thy walls. Go ahead.
>> And their kings shall minister unto
thee.
>> Uhhuh.
>> For in my wrath I smoke thee, but in my
favor I have had mercy on thee. Go
ahead.
>> Therefore, thy gates shall be opened
continually.
>> Come on.
>> They shall not be shut day nor night.
>> Go ahead.
>> That men may bring unto thee the forces
of the Gentiles.
>> Go ahead. and their that their kings may
be brought for the nation and kingdom.
>> Who's the nation and kingdom here?
>> It's it's five minute closings.
>> Oh, no, no, no. Five minute warning.
Five minute warning
>> till Okay, got you, brother.
>> Yeah, no worries. So, can I can I
respond to you then?
>> Yeah, read it again. Read it again. That
last
>> Oh, you don't got to read all cuz I
don't want you to waste your time.
>> It's the book of Isaiah chapter 60 and
verse 12.
>> Hold on.
Relax. Relax. In Isaiah 60 when it said
the nation and kingdom
>> that shall not serve thee. Who's the
nation and kingdom?
>> Those who are against Israel.
>> Only those that who are against Israel.
The one
>> when it says those.
>> Who's the V then in the context?
>> It just told you. It just said those who
do will not serve you. Right. So these
are the ones who are in the context.
>> Uh Israel.
>> Israel.
>> Yeah. The Israel and those who are
joined. All of the nations and kingdom
that will not serve the Israelites shall
what?
>> They'll be destroyed.
>> They'll be destroyed. So in the kingdom
of heaven, all of the heathen have to
serve who?
>> No, no, no. Watch this. This is where
you're getting a mix.
>> In the kingdom of heaven, all of all of
the nations have to serve who?
>> Watch this. Watch this. Can I answer you
now fully?
>> I appreciate it. I appreciate you. So,
notice how we just broke this down,
ladies and gentlemen. according to who
the kingdom is made up of. It's made up
of every tribe, every people, every
tongue, every nation, every language.
And he ignored that and went here, went
to the uh to the shuffle and then tried
to say, "See, strangers are going to
serve which ones? The ones that are
against the people of God." So, it's not
every stranger on the earth, but only
those who are against God. So, when you
the strangers who join themselves to
Israel, they are also called people of
God. Matter of fact, hey, give me uh
give me Isaiah.
>> Give me Isaiah. Give me Give me Isaiah
where it talk about Egyptians and the
Assyrians.
>> Oh, I love that verse.
>> Watch this. I bet you do.
>> Watch this. We going to see who all the
people
>> Isaiah chapter 19 verse 23.
>> Yeah.
>> On that day there will be a road from
Egypt to Assyria, and the Assyrians will
come into Egypt, and the Egyptians into
Syria, and the Egyptians will worship
with the Assyrians. Hold on. Verse 24.
>> On that day, Israel will be the third
party to Egypt and Assyria, a blessing
in the midst of the earth, whom the Lord
of armies has blessed, saying, "Blessed
is Egypt, my people, and Assyria, the
work of my hands, and Israel my
inheritance."
>> Whoa, whoa, whoa,
>> whoa, whoa, whoa. You mean to Wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait. You mean to tell
me that Yahweh just said that a foreign
nation who used to enslave Israel that
he's now calling Egypt his people?
>> You mean to tell You mean to tell me
that the Assyrians who once stood up
against Israel are redeemed and now
they're called
>> the work of his hand? So then Israel and
then wait just so we don't get it
confused. It says that Israel is a third
in this party. And what does it say
about Israel?
>> Inheritance. So, we got Israel, my
inheritance, Assyria, the work of my
hands, and Egypt, my people.
>> That's bad. That's bad. You ready? You
ready for the response?
>> Hey. Hey. My logic. Pay attention.
My logic, pay attention.
Ready.
>> This is This right here is Isaiah 19 and
the LXX. You agree with the LXX, Mr.
Georgia?
>> Sure.
>> Yeah. This Isaiah 19 and 25, okay? It
says, "The Lord of heaven's armies will
pronounce a blessing over the earth,
saying, "Blessed be my people," right?
>> Uh-huh.
>> Right. Blessed be my people
>> that are in Egypt and among the
Assyrians, even Israel, my heritage.
Now, this is also something that is in
the book of Zechariah. So, what is this
showing? This is talking about the
Israelites who were in those captivities
and in those lands. I'm going to show
you something. This is Zechariah. This
is Zechariah right here. Chapter 10 and
10.
>> You got it. If you got it, get it first.
>> No, I want Zechariah 10 and 10.
>> And just let you know right after this,
you can respond to it and then we'll be
done. We'll go to five in the closing.
>> I got you. Zechariah 10 and 10. Read it.
>> It's the book of Zechariah chapter 10
and verse 10. And I will bring them
again also out of the land of Egypt.
>> Out of what?
>> Out of the land of Egypt.
>> Go ahead.
>> And gather them out of Assyria.
>> So is this Israelites?
>> According to what?
>> A good eye.
>> Is this Israelites here?
>> According to what?
>> Zechariah 10:10. Are these Israelites
here?
>> The ones who are fighting against the
people. Yeah.
>> The the ones that are what?
>> Fighting against the people.
>> Who's fighting against the people?
>> God.
>> No. These right here that are getting
called out of Egypt and Assyria, are
these Israelites? Yes or no?
>> What does it say?
>> Read it again.
>> The book of Zechariah.
>> Can you read one verse? Read the context
and show me who it's talking about.
>> This is Zechariah 10 and 10.
>> You gave me one verse.
>> You got to read it.
>> You got to read what the verse.
>> Read it. Just listen.
>> This is the book of Zechariah 10 and
verse 10. Go ahead.
>> I will bring them again out of the land
of Egypt and gather them out of Assyria.
>> Go ahead. and I will bring them into the
land of Gilead and Lebanon and place
shall not be found for them.
>> Are those Israelites?
>> Let me let me respond to you. I have no
problem acknowledging that these are
Israelites. However, you're you would
make an error if you're trying to say
that it's just Israel because what
happened when God brought Israel out of
Egypt? Was it just Israelites that came
out?
>> No, it was a mixed multitude. So I have
no problem with a mixed multitude coming
being brought out out of Assyria and out
of Egypt that are not ethnic Israelites.
>> The point the point that's being made
here is you're saying let let him finish
this point real quick. I'm going to be
real quick one sentence. The point that
you were trying to make was Egypt and
Assyria were also called by God's name.
When I read this in the LXX and then I
also gave a supporting uh verse right
here in Zechariah 10 when it was talking
about Egypt in Assyria is talking about
the children of Israel. That's literally
what I just proved in the Greek and with
a supporting text in the Hebrew. So we
going to do the closing now.
>> Five minute closing. Who's going first?
I
>> I started first.
Let me um let me get this ready.
>> Hey start.
>> Yeah. Uh uh go ahead and give me uh
>> go ahead and give me that. Not everyone
is from Abraham is from Abraham.
>> We got to close it out, right?
>> Romans nine.
>> Oh yeah.
>> You you take Paul as an authority,
right? He's apostle.
>> I don't got a problem with Paul.
>> Okay, good.
>> I like Paul, man.
>> All right, good.
>> It's a good brother.
>> We love Paul.
[Music]
We're going to do this and then we're
going to do the Solomon uh prayer.
>> He says uh not everyone who is of
Abraham is is from Abraham. Romans 9.
It's like the beginning I think.
>> Romans 9 and verse 6 and
>> Oh man. Thank you, bro. See, that's what
I'm talking about, man. This what this
what this what
>> read it in the ESV when the word
descended is not even there in the in
the Greek.
>> I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm
sorry.
>> I'm just saying.
>> Trying to help him out.
>> Romans 9:6.
But it is not as though the word of God
has failed, for they are not all Israel
who are descended from Israel. What?
>> Verse seven.
>> Nor are they all children because they
are Abraham's seed. But through Isaac
your seed shall be named.
>> Wow.
>> That is the children of the flesh are
not the children of God, but the
children of the promise are considered
as seed.
>> Beautiful. Now, this is the this is what
I love about this. What I love about
this is that
>> that you're not born
>> of God according to the flesh, according
to the will of man, according to what I
want or you want, according to where
your daddy's from or your mama's from,
>> but you're born of God according to the
will of God.
>> And God can raise up children of Abraham
from these stones.
>> And we praise God that he raised up
children of Abraham out of us Gentiles,
>> out of us non-Israelites. And what I
like about this, what I like about this,
you guys, is that what he's referring to
is in Hosea, but Paul is interpreting
this and relates this to the now times
for those who put their faith in the
Messiah and are born again into the
faith and family of Abraham. Now, give
me uh that that uh that prayer from
Solomon and we'll wrap this up.
>> Because I went what I I that was the
actually that was the first New
Testament verse I quoted all day, isn't
it?
>> That's fast, man. That's crazy, man.
Man, God is good. Let's let's go back to
the Old Testament.
>> First Kings 8:41.
>> Everybody pay attention to this. This is
Solomon's prayer
>> concerning the foreigner who is not of
your people Israel.
>> Wait, say that again. Who's not what?
>> Who is not of your people Israel.
>> So a non-Israelite foreigner, watch
Solomon's prayer.
>> If he comes from a far country for your
name's sake, they will hear of your
great name and your strong hand and of
your outstretched arm. So if he comes
and prays towards this house, listen in
heaven your dwelling place and do
according to all for which the foreigner
calls to you. So hold on a second. So
Solomon is having this temple built. And
he's praying not just for the
Israelites, but for the non-Israelites
that when they hear of God's goodness,
when they hear of God's glory, that
they're going to rush to the temple and
they're going to offer their
supplications and prayers to God. And he
says, "Please do whatever they ask
>> in order that all the peoples of the
earth may know your name to fear you as
do your people Israel."
>> So here we have God is not just a God of
the Jews, but he's a God of all flesh.
And this is being fulfilled, not just
back then, but today.
>> First Kings 8:41. There you go.
>> There we go.
>> All right. So, I'm going to I'm going to
start off my closing with Ro with with
Romans 9 cuz you stopped at a specific
verse for a reason. So, I'm going to
start at verse four where it says I'm
going actually start at verse three. For
I could wish that myself were a curse
from Christ. For my brethren, my
kinsmen, according to the flesh, who are
Israelites, to whom pertainth the
adoption, and the glory, and the
covenants, and the giving of the law,
and the service of God, and the
promises, whose are the fathers of whom
as concerning the flesh, Christ came who
was over all, God bless forever. Amen.
This what you this what you started at.
Not as though the word of God hath taken
none effect. For they are not all Israel
which are of Israel. Right here it says
nothing about descendants. Because if
you understand the histo
revelations 3:9, the blasphemy of them
that say they are Jews and are not. Was
not the [__] and the Herodians
claiming to be Israelites here? Does not
in the book of Acts Jusilla was known as
a Jewish? Herod was king over the Jews.
These are [__] This is what this is
talking about. And you're going to see
when you keep reading. Neither because
they are the seed of Abraham are they
all children. But in Isaac shall thy
seed be called. Abraham had more
children than Isaac. That is they which
are the children of the flesh. These are
not the children of God, but the
children of the promise are counted for
the seed. Who are the children of the
promise? We just read that in verse
four. For this is the word of promise.
At this time will come and Sarah shall
have a son. And not only this, but when
Rebecca also had conceived by one, even
by our father Isaac. For the children
being not yet born, neither having done
any good or evil,
>> that the purpose of God according to
election might stand, not of works, but
of him that calleth. It was said unto
her, "The elder shall serve the
younger."
>> What shall we say then? Is this an
unrighteousness with God? God forbid.
>> You ain't even noticed. I skipped the
verse. I did that on purpose. As it is
written,
>> cuz everybody love this, right?
Everybody, all everybody, this is
Israelite. Go to As it is written,
Jacob. Yo, you hilarious. Jacob have I
love, but Esau have I ate it.
Why didn't you keep reading? And just
like I said in the Greek, descendant is
not even there, brother.
>> It's not even there.
>> Do you understand? Now, going back,
let's let's drop back down cuz I just
want to deal with something real quick.
It's time.
>> No, no, no.
>> It says, "Even us whom he hath called,
not of the Jews only, but also of the
Gentiles." You just quoted this, but
look what it says. as he saith also in
hosi is which is Hosea I will call them
my people which are not my people and
her beloved which are not my beloved in
the context of Hosea that's talking
about the Israelites brother you can't
sit there and now include the church
that's ridiculous that's why even when
you keep reading what does it say right
here in verse 7 Isaiah also crith
concerning Israel though the number of
the children of Israel be as the sand of
the sea, a remnant shall be saved.
>> So what is this showing? That has
nothing to do with now the church is
right here. That's talking about the
children of Israel and the children of
Judah.
Very simple to understand. That's what
the context is talking about. It ain't
the time yet. Is it
>> one minute? You see, I got one minute
left.
>> So let's go.
Let's go to
>> go back to go back to uh Hey, let's go
back to Isaiah 60 and 15.
>> Matthew 28 for me.
>> Not at all. Not at all.
>> Matthew the book of Isaiah.
>> 16 and 15.
>> Chapter 60.
>> Isaiah 60 and verse 15.
>> Listen, this is what you got to realize.
Read
>> the book of Isaiah 60 and verse 15.
Whereas thou has been broken
>> and hated.
>> No, no. Where it says uh those that
don't serve you.
>> Oh, this is the book of Isaiah
>> chapter 60 and verse 12. For the nation
and kingdom that will not serve thee.
>> The nation and kingdom that's not going
to serve Israel, this what has to be
understood. Read,
>> shall perish.
>> Shall perish. There's there's going to
be also a class system within heaven.
The children of Israel are going to
rule. That's why even in Isaiah 2, what
do you have? All of the nations coming
in what? Having to learn the ways of
Jacob. That's what the kingdom of heaven
is. The children of Israel ruling
underneath the King of Kings and the
Lord of Lords, who we all agree is Jesus
Christ. We all agree that that's Jesus
Christ. And with the children of Israel
ruling, the rest of the nations are
going to have to be under subjection
underneath the children of Israel.
>> All right, let's clap. Clap everybody.
Awesome.
So, uh, everybody, that concludes our
debates, uh, that we had the
headtoheads. However, if, uh, there are
some other Hebrew Israelites or y'all
want to get at it, get some, you know,
we're still here. So, um, other than
that, we can take a little break. But
with that being said, man, y'all stop.
Thank you so much for participating,
bro. Awesome debate. Um, it was fun. Uh,
Cap Tazarak, that was fun to watch, man.
IP inspiring philosophy. So, if you guys
like this type of content, make sure you
guys hit the like button, subscribe, put
in the comment section who you thought
won, who your what your favorite verse
was, and what y'all thought. Man, I
think this was an easy dub for the
Christians, man.